devil fruit axons and the heartbreaking
moment poured straight from the manga
Netflix recently dropped the official
trailer for one piece and fans like what
they see warning spoilers ahead
the one piece trailer kicks off in an
epic fashion depicting the incredibly
influential public execution of Goldie
Roger in one piece Goldie Roger is the
most legendary pirate in history and the
captain of the Roger Pirates he became
the pirate king by Conquering the grand
line and obtaining the one piece while
his accomplishments on the Seas made him
a legend he also put him directly in the
world government's crosshairs dying of
an incurable disease Goldie Roger turned
himself in and the government planned to
execute him publicly as a message to all
Pirates instead with his last words
Roger refused to reveal the location of
the one piece inspiring a new generation
of pirates including Luffy to search for
the hidden treasure and claim his title
of King of the Pirates ushering in the
Golden Age of pirates from the looks of
it Netflix's one piece sticks close to
the source material for Roger's
execution with practically a shot for
shot adaptation of the same scene from
the anime with that in mind chances are
the live-action series gives us a
glimpse at some of the Roger Pirates as
both Shanks and buggy attended their
Captain's execution and thus set to
appear in one piece
speaking of Shanks the one piece trailer
also gives fans a first look at the Fun
favorite character in live action
including his heroics are not only sent
Luffy on the trajectory of becoming a
pirate but it's one of the series most
iconic moments in the trailer we get a
quick glimpse of Shanks and Luffy on a
small boat as a giant monster erupts
from the sea while it may not look like
much to the average viewer one piece
fans will quickly recognize this as a
defining moment in Luffy's story where
shang's sacrifices his arm to save the
boy from a sea king no big deal it's
just an arm Luffy early in one piece a
young Luffy finds himself thrown into
the ocean and able to swim because of
his devil fruit Powers with a massive
Sea King ready to eat him just as the
monster goes in for a bite Shanks saves
Luffy sacrificing his left arm to ensure
the boy survived shortly after Shanks
and his red-haired Pirates depart
leaving Luffy in fuchsia Village but not
before the captain gives him his iconic
Straw Hat inspiring Luffy to become a
greater pirate than shanks
of course the biggest draw of One Piece
are seeing all the Beloved characters
brought to live action for the first
time and Netflix's trailer features
plenty of heroes and villains the straw
hat crew is front and center in the
trailer with Luffy Zorro Nami usob and
Sanji looking as if the fan favorite
pirates walk directly off the pages of
age hero odar's manga we even see the
crew wearing a few different outfits
further showcasing how closely one piece
is sticking to the source material
outside of the straw hats the trailer
shows Marine vice admiral Monkey D GARP
in attendance at Gaudi raja's execution
you also see alvida the captain of the
alvida pirate and her ship the Miss love
duck we even get a quick look at dracul
mihawk one of the seven Warlords of the
Sea and the large part of Zorro's early
story
what makes Netflix's one piece at like
such a promising live-action adaptation
is that the production didn't heavily
rely on visual effects to bring the
world to life building massive sets
instead and the trailer shows them off
in all their Glory from the beginning we
see logtown where Goldie Roger was born
and executed the production even built
the tall execution platform where One
Piece season one could end later in the
trailer baratier is in full view where a
few important battles will go down
before Luffy Zorro and Nami add Sanji to
their crew throughout the trailer we get
glimpses of other iconic one-piece
locations and their production also
built multiple pirate ships to film on
like the going Mary and the Miss love
duck while it may not seem like a
massive feat Netflix could have easily
used green screens and visual effects
when filming one piece and it's almost
surprising that they didn't given
Hollywood's current Reliance on visual
effects instead they had Crews build
them on location and from the trailer it
seems that investment paid off as
aichiro odar's beautiful world looks
incredible
while Netflix relied on practical
effects to bring the locations of one
piece to life that isn't the case for
the devil-free powers which are also on
full display Luffy's Powers come from
the gum gum fruit which he ate as a
child giving his entire body the
properties of rubber with their loopy
can stretch bounce Bend twist and
inflate any part of his body with even
crazier techniques coming later in the
series Netflix's trailer holds out most
of Luffy's abilities Until the End
showcasing them drinker's battle against
arlong we see him stretch his mouth legs
and arms showing off one of his
signature moves suddenly the one piece
trailer also gives our first look of
Buggy's Chop Chop fruit which lets him
split his body into pieces reassembling
them at will
although the trailer only showcases
Luffy and Buggy's devil fruit abilities
that a chance one piece could feature
another devil fruit user we don't know
exactly how much season 1 of the Netflix
series will cover but assuming it rubs
up the East blue Saga it could end with
the introduction of Captain smoker a
ruthless Marine with smoke Powers either
way Luffy in the straw hat crew will
have their hands forward the show's
confirmed villains
accent Morgan doesn't outright appear in
the one piece trailer but Netflix sure
does a lot to tease his imposing
presence in one shot just an ax and a
hand take up the entire screen well
General audiences may not look twice at
the shot fans of the anime will
instantly understand the reference and
then just as Luffy is gearing up to
unleash a massive stretchy kick
eagle-eyed fans will spot a poster of
Morgan behind the pirate Captain it's
difficult to determine exactly what the
Marine Captain looks like berta's metal
jaw stands out very clearly monpi's fans
know that axhan Morgan is Luffy's first
adversary that challenges his plans of
becoming the pirate king as the main
antagonist of the first Arc of One Piece
Morgan abuses his military power ruling
shellstown with an iron fist or at least
an ax fist you get it he has a ax for a
hand although Morgan is a worthy
adversary for a young and experienced
Luffy he won't be the straw hat
Captain's biggest challenge in Netflix's
one piece
unlike axand Morgan our lung shows a
shark face throughout the one-piece
trailer and the fish man has the same
menacing and imposing presence as he
does in the anime I'll do the kindness
of killing you all together without
diving too deep into spoilers arlang
plays a pivotal role in the straw Hat's
early story particularly regarding Nami
her backstory and her official addition
to the crew Luffy runs into ah long
after making his way through aksand
Morgan buggy and the black cat Pirates
so don't expect to see him until the end
of season 1. however he'll be worth the
wait as he gives Luffy an immense
obstacle to overcome bringing an
interesting fighting style with him a
humanoid shark he primarily attacks with
his long serrated nose but during his
fight with Luffy he pulls out a few
crazy moves it'll be interesting to see
if they make it to the live-action one
piece
while our long will be a massive
challenge for Luffy and the straw hats
to overcome there's an incredibly
emotional moments that comes during the
story arc one that long time one piece
fans will have to emotionally prepare to
re-experience in the live-action series
[Music]
I'm gonna kick your ass cause no one
messes with my friends when Luffy and
zaro meet Nami she has a very
complicated past and this moment pulls
on every emotional heartstring relating
to her tragic backstory a series
introduces Nami as a thief stealing
treasure from other Pirates and bringing
them back to her captain and pirate crew
are long on the are long Pirates it's
definitely a one-sided relationship with
nami feeling trapped rather than
enjoying her time with the Fishman
Pirates eventually she can no longer
take our lungs abuse and in a very
emotional moment Luffy plates as a straw
hat on her head signaling he'll do
whatever it takes for his friend to make
it even better Netflix rips the scene
straight from the Manga and Anime
proving that one piece is sticking close
to the source material for its
live-action adaptation
[Music]
in the trailer Luffy and Kobe look at a
wall of wanted posters the first the
most obvious is alvida who both Luffy
and Kobe have already met and are wanted
poster reveals of 5 million Berry bounty
on her head in the next shot Foxy's
wanted pose through his unfold display
revealing an impressive 24 million Berry
bounty on the captain of the foxy
Pirates then there's Bellamy's wanted
poster Bellamy is another antagonist a
straw hats will eventually run into but
the earliest that could happen is
probably season two although it may be a
while until these teasers pay off it's
nice that one piece is planning ahead
expecting the Netflix series to be a hit
has Garner enough attention to return
for multiple Seasons if the trailer is
anything to go off of the teasers will
eventually pay off as a live-action one
piece looks as promising as ever
where's my face
foreign